it was the small hours of the morning
before she came out to celebrate but
Georgia Maloney was energized by Victory
and she promised to unite her country
it seems clear to me that what came out
from the first projections is that
Italians in these general elections have
expressed a clear indication that they
want a center-right government led by
Brothers of Italy a party the brothers
of Italy is now the biggest and will
lead a right-wing coalition government
if we will be called to govern this
country we will do it for all Italians
for everybody with the goal of uniting
this people of stressing what unites
rather than what divides Maloney doesn't
look sound or act like most Italian
politicians and that's probably what got
her elected four years ago the brothers
of Italy got just four percent in across
the general election and Georgia Maloney
looked like a bit part player how times
have changed
to become her country's first woman
prime minister and certain to play a
leading role on the world's political
stage she has tried to add humor to her
campaign
but there are plenty worried about the
future her Coalition will include two of
Italy's most controversial leaders
Matthew salvini the far right head of
the league party
and Silvio Berlusconi now nearly 86
years old but still an influential
outspoken showman but turnout in this
election was desperately low Italy wants
fresh ideas
Maloney's supporters savored their
Victory with noise and energy but
winning power was one thing using it
will be quite another challenge
Adam Parson Sky News Rome